[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's seven o'clock I'm Dermot mernahan
and this is a Sky News tonight question
and answer program as teachers in
England and Wales vote to go on strike
thousands of teachers from the National
Education Union will strike in a dispute
with the government about pay
we want to find a resolution to this
dispute
but that resolution has to be on the
basis of new money to pay teachers and
support staff what they are worth
industrial action will begin in February
more than 23 000 schools in England and
Wales are expected to be affected as the
government calls the decision deeply
disappointing
we all know that during the pandemic
they have had a lot of disruption to
their education and we're still trying
to catch up from that so it is deeply
disappointing
answer right the next day I will be
answering as many of your questions as
we can live with a panel of experts as
we look at our children teachers and
schools are going to be affected by the
strikes and what the government is
planning to do about it
[Music]
a very good evening and welcome to a Sky
News tonight question and answer program
about the teachers strikes in England
and Wales today thousands of teachers
voted to take industrial action over
seven days in February and March in a
dispute with the government about pay
more than 90 percent of people who voted
in a ballot by the National Education
Union the Neu voted in favor of strike
action but a separate ballot by the
National Association of head teachers
did not meet the legal threshold for
turnout and tonight we'll try to answer
your questions about the strikes with
our experts who are going to join me in
the studio in a few minutes time and
before we speak to them let's hear from
the General Secretary of the National
Education Union Mary bastet as she
announced the industrial action
we will continue to seek to negotiate
Anytime Anyplace anywhere we want to
find a resolution to this dispute but
that resolution has to be on the basis
of new money to pay teachers and support
staff what they are worth
and whilst we seek to negotiate we will
be campaigning to bring parents and
other stakeholders with us
our action is absolutely not designed to
hurt them all to disadvantage are pupils
and our young people rather it is a
stand we must take now if things are not
to deteriorate further
well these are the details of who will
be striking under when they'll be taking
that action on Wednesday the 1st of
February all eligible members from the
National Education Union in England and
Wales will take action then on Tuesday
the 14th of February all eligible
members in Wales will strike on Tuesday
the 28th of February action will be
taken in the northern Northwest
Yorkshire and the Humber regions
then on the first day of March all
eligible Neu members in the East
Midlands West Midlands and Eastern
regions in England will take action
and the next day on the 2nd of March
teaches in London the southeast and the
South West will go on strike then on
Wednesday the 15th of March all eligible
Neu members in England and Wales will
take action once again then again on
Thursday the 16th of March
so variety of national and Regional
actions taking place they will let me
introduce today's panel who will be
answering your questions you've been
sending them into us all day we have the
founder of the Oasis Academy's trust
which represents more than 52 schools
he's Steve chalk also the editorial
director of netmums Jennifer house the
Neu member and head teacher at gospel
Oak Primary School in North London John
Hayes and uh just to alert you a bit
later on the former education secretary
Justine Greening will be joining us here
in the studio so as I say if any of your
questions coming in as you can see a
hand-picked panel of experts to deal
with them so let's start first with the
teacher's demands the core of the
dispute and so your first question very
welcome to all panelists the first
question then is quite simply What do
teachers want why are they striking that
is from
Adam or do they want more money
well let's go uh straight to the teacher
what is the nub of the action
so essentially
um teachers pay over the last decade
hasn't kept up with inflation so year on
year where there have been pay Rises and
quite frequently there have been none uh
it has meant that given given that
inflation rate Teachers Pay hasn't kept
up and therefore teachers effectively
are earning less and less each year
um but I'm a head teacher and uh still a
member of the National Education Union I
also voted to strike and my biggest
concern around all of this is much as
the teachers deserve that pay rise and
we have given them the pay rise that
that they have been awarded this year
school budgets haven't been compensated
and we haven't been able to keep up and
so the stress on the system right now is
totally unsustainable uh that's my
greatest concern so I think teachers do
need more money it does need to reflect
what they do and and the inflation rate
that it has to compete with but equally
that needs to be a fully funded pay rise
and that's really really important and
fully funded is a very important part of
that isn't it Steve chalk because if
it's not fully funded then any change in
pay any increase in Pay comes out of the
school's budget absolutely so um I as
you've said
um am responsible for 52 schools I
founded a charity called Oasis and
besides anything else we run schools so
you might expect me to take a view that
says at all costs you know this is a
terrible thing and and this action is
wrong I don't feel that at all I very
much agree with what John has said over
the 20 years that Oasis has been run in
schools I have seen the funding dribble
away dribble away from education I've
seen classes stripped of the learning
assistants that provide the individual
care to kids I've seen them stripped of
the resources to prevent to produce a
wider curriculum I've seen more and more
of a straight jacket arrive around kids
that doesn't cater for all their needs
because there's not the fun in there to
do it and someone has to stand up and
say that this is wrong so it's going to
be very disruptive
I'm not a member of any teaching Union
but I totally understand why those who
find themselves in this position in the
end need to stand up and say this cannot
carry on I think the point about a fully
funded pay rise is important because
perhaps John didn't point out is as
precisely as I would at 4086 we run 52
schools the rise in teachers salaries
that we wanted to give has cost us four
million pounds this year 4 million
pounds out of our budget stripped out of
classrooms to fund Teachers Pay rise but
that's because though the government
announced the pay rise they didn't give
us a penny towards it so so my friends
who are members of the Neu and the other
teaching unions like me they love kids
they love kids let's just start in there
in terms of those Rising costs because
it's not just that then this unfunded
pay rise but also at the same time just
general economic conditions increasing
heating costs yeah yeah food yeah so
that was four million pounds for the
extra for the extra salaries
um the the energy price Rises been
astronomical I was in one of our schools
just um the other day and their energy
bill at this time last year uh was three
thousand pounds this time this year it's
16 000 pounds so so the reality is if we
want to provide kids in our country with
education we have to invest in it and
the other thing I'd say and then I'll
shut up because I've been talking for
too long 40 of teachers new teachers who
come into the profession 40 of them
leave within five years they leave
because they become eager to teach it's
a vocation they they come that way they
leave because they're one that's got a
lot to say and I would have put it more
politely than that but in terms of right
you're going to stop because I want to
hear from Jennifer and Jennifer in a way
can I tell you you know you're
representing a lot of parents of course
but a lot of those parents I suspect
will be teachers as well indeed
um we see with net mum's parents that
the majority of them support teachers
they understand the challenges they also
understand that teachers are there
because they love to teach they love
kids they love being part of the
educational process and bring a lot of
passion to it at the same time
parents a lot of what is happening is
it's just it's being filtered down to
parents so you've got the teachers and
the teaching units on this side you've
got the government on this side and
they're playing Hardball and they're not
negotiating and as a result
Everything Is Falling Again to parents
and the parents that we've been talking
to especially today as it became more
obvious this was going to happen they
were saying you know they just you know
one and said oh my heart just dropped
when I realized it was going to happen
because it felt like locked down all
over again where suddenly it's down
we're gonna get on to that yeah the
effect on on all these missed years of
education already and now it looks like
we're going to get more of that but just
storm there on on the core of the
dispute just to go back to you John
Hayes on on this issue of of money even
if a settlement is reached some kind of
compromise where do you think the money
will come from you said where you think
it should come from
foreign
I think changing the charitable status
of Independent Schools is a critical
step that needs to be taken I think
we've seen uh all sorts of money leaking
away uh to those in big business who
somehow managed to avoid paying the tax
that they should I think there are
plenty of ways that the government can
find the money to invest in children but
you know I think it's it's absolutely
vital that they do this you know as
everyone on the panel has said so far
the children are the most important
thing if we can't do right by them right
now then we're not much of a country and
I think the government just have to
prioritize State education and make sure
that they that they do what is needed
because it is it is critical
um and I would like to come back on the
on the points that were made about the
impact on parents if I may
um the the parents as Steve has quite
rightly pointed out have seen the
decline of State Community Schools over
the last decade it's happened slowly
they may not have noticed but if they
look now at the Staffing levels in their
children's schools as opposed to that
which they were say 10 years ago they
will then see what's happening in our
schools they will see that there are
fewer teaching assistants that children
with special educational needs have less
fewer opportunities there are less
resources available to them
um all of this is is is is is is
damaging the kids who are in our schools
right now yeah that has to be our
priority but of course missed days I
mean as Jennifer was pointing out there
John you know Miss more missed days more
disrupted teaching than does affect
those kids it it can't not
totally don't get me wrong we shouldn't
have to do this we shouldn't be in this
position where we've been asking and
begging and campaigning for decades we
shouldn't have to be in the position of
saying this is the last resort because
strike action should be the last resort
and it is this is us saying you've got
to correct this for children right now
there's kind of a direct parallel isn't
there with what we're hearing from so
many people working in the in the NHS
um different situations of course but
then um some some harm to those that
they they care for and and nurture can I
just ask if we've got two specific
questions here
um and maybe between you
um John and Steve you can answer this
Steve what about school support staff
will teaching assistants join the strike
I mean they're it's just so so important
in in all schools now do we know are
they going to to join the action well I
I defer to John on the technicalities of
this but the point I would make is yeah
teaching assistants are really important
to education and their salaries their
wages are so low we have so many
teaching assistants in schools that that
enable the child who learns differently
who needs individual attention they're
essential to the system but their
salaries are for many of them are below
20 000 pounds and if you're trying for
instance to live in the city I live in
one responsibility yes yet the
responsibility is huge but yeah the
responsibility actually what the point
that John didn't make is not only have
the resources drained away from
education over the last decade but the
responsibilities have risen and risen
and risen and risen so you're asking
more of less people and yet these people
are on low salaries they're struggling
to live we find a lot of our teachers
one of the things we do is we run food
banks and we find a lot of forever for
our families because we were work in
poor communities but we find more and
more of our lower paid staff using the
food banks that's what we've got to
address yeah yeah and as I say parallel
understand with what we're hearing from
the NHS so John just the specifics of
that teaching assistance School support
staff to your knowledge of a joining in
the the actions as well
I don't think they've been balloted for
the to take the same specific action
that Neu members have
um we know that some other member some
other unions haven't been able to meet
the government's very very restrictive
thresholds for taking strike action but
I think if we do see picket lines
outside schools then it I would not be
surprised if Trade union members who are
support staff uh would May well refuse
to cross those picket lines
um and and that's that's going to be a
real tension
um and I would absolutely understand if
they refused to do so they are as Steve
said they are absolutely vital they are
some of the lowest paid people in our
schools and and without them we just
can't function and
you know as I said in terms of of job
loss when when the pay Rises aren't
fully funded at my own School 18 months
ago we lost the equivalent of eight
members of support staff because I
couldn't pay for them
um the the knock-on effect that that's
had on the children on the staff Who
Remain
um with with increasing issues yes that
have Arisen from the pandemic we've also
seen an explosion of special educational
needs across the country particularly in
early years it is those support staff
who are often absolutely vital in making
sure that the provision is right for
those kids and and we don't have enough
of them we can't afford them if in at
some point in the future their unions
ballot them to take a strike action I
would be fully supportive of that okay
listen we're going to take a short break
now thank you all very much indeed for
your contributions so far I want to come
back we're going to look at well the
government side of the equation what's
their negotiating position what are they
going to do about these strikes we'll be
tapping into the expertise of the former
education secretary no less Justine
Greening
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Midlands correspondent we can reveal
that the driver who hit Harry Dunn is 42
year old am circulus just met the
president and we never thought we'd get
this far this is what they're up against
is back-breaking work
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid change seems
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to a Sky News Tonight
program about the teachers strikes now
to take place in England and Wales uh
bring our panel back in in just a moment
or two but first the government have
said that they are deeply disappointed
with the announcement this evening the
National Education Union's decision to
strike speaking after that announcement
the education secretary said that it
will have a damaging impact on pupils
learning
well we have the independent pay review
body for pay
um which which of course we have
accepted in full and it was actually a
lot higher than all the schools had
budgeted for
um and that's why we've also provided
additional funding but you know it is
deeply disappointing for parents and and
and for children and it will have an
impact on children and obviously after
the pandemic that's that's going to be
quite
um you know difficult because we're
already you know trying to catch up with
uh children
um and you know it's particularly
disappointing because we have the very
first thing I was asked to do was to get
a secure extra funding two billion
pounds for the for next year and the
year after which is what we did
um so it is extremely disappointing
education secretary there Jillian Keegan
well let's bring our panel back in for
today's program and uh we're going to
take more questions on there about the
government's position in particular
we've got the founder of the Oasis
Academy's trust Steve chalk still here
the editorial director of net mum's
Jennifer house and the NAU member and
head teacher at gospel Oak Primary
School in North London John Hayes now
also joining us for this segment the
former education secretary Justine
Greening is also here very good to see
Justine Greening so uh uh one of your
successes quite a few down the line
though it changes in position over those
intervening years but the key question
is we've asked the question about what
the teachers are demanding and of course
the other side of the coin and this is
the question could the strikes be called
off if a deal is struck with the
government well of course they could but
is the government-minded to strike a
deal I suppose exactly and I think first
of all
as everyone has said I mean this is
obviously a disaster for children's
education to lose even more days
after the covid schools shut down and we
know that the children that suffered the
most during that shutdown were the ones
that were the least privileged so this
is a country that's trying to level up
and those people right at the sharp end
are now going to have even less
education so so that's the first thing
and I know that teachers
up and down the country are hugely
passionate about their students and
education so I think on a positive level
it was really good that Gillian Keegan
was round the table with the teacher
unions and I hope they can keep talking
because the sooner this gets sourced out
the better at the same time I think
if you're in government that there
probably needs to be a sense of you
can't book the markets there's a teacher
labor market out there when you look at
teacher recruitment in the last round
some crucial subjects like physics only
17 of teachers uh were recruited into
those training places under par and
maths so actually both sides in a sense
are going to have to come together to
work out how we have a teacher pay and
reward approach that means we do get the
teachers that our school system needs
and puts pupils at the center of it
because especially as you're talking
there about you know these these two
missed years crucial years in in so many
children's life and of course we know
about the vast numbers of children
who've just disappeared all together
from the school register during the
lockdowns you just haven't gone back so
this second question following on from
that why Justin Green do you think the
government has let it get to this point
Point given that need for leveling up
giving that need for catching up and and
here we are facing more disruption well
I think there's a lot of pressures on
the school system and I think that
post-covered
um you saw sir Kevin Collins someone who
I worked with as education secretary
have a huge amount of respect for
he comes forward with a catch-up plan to
to help people recover their education
and in the end that plan wasn't fully
funded and taken forward now there is
more money going into education over the
next two years I think it's eight
percent both years so that will help but
I think there's been an extremely
difficult period that teachers have gone
through
and although we are obviously an
understanding we focus on the NHS and
the Very visible pressures the NHS is
under
for the education system these pressures
are much more invisible you can't see
the fact that a child has lost out on
their learning and what that will mean
for their future it is very hard to sort
of almost project that and so I think
there's a sense of things reaching that
crisis point in a sense where teachers
are trying to now have that discussion
with the
um with with the the government about
the resourcing and the pay system that
will be required but in the end the Lost
education that children are going to
have is not going to help and I I can
speak from personal experience I was in
the school system in the 80s I lost days
of my education down to school strikes
then and in a sense as a pupil I just
felt caught in the middle of this I
didn't have a vote it's not like I could
make my mind a poo was right or wrong
and then vote out that government or
vote out the you know vote against the
teachers striking and so I just think
it's it's not acceptable that children
and young people end up in the middle of
this and in a sense the adults need to
sort this out let me ask John how's that
because John you were nodding with that
I mean it's not acceptable is it that
the innocent parties in this become the
injured parties is there is there a way
is there any regular room here any any
potential For A Meeting of Minds that
could avert this
well I I think we've already heard from
Mary bellsted that the Neu leadership is
ready to negotiate as soon as the
government is ready to negotiate
um but I would I would totally agree we
shouldn't be going on strike absolutely
not we shouldn't have to do that we now
have to do that because it's the only
way that we're being taken seriously
this item would not be on this evening
on your news coverage had the Neu not
voted to go on strike we wouldn't be
talking about it you know it the school
funding is incredibly technical
incredibly detailed and it's only when
we do things like this that we're taking
notice of I think somebody commented I
think it was Justine who commented that
the government that the that this is the
biggest disaster for children's
education I would argue that the current
government is the biggest disaster for
children's education right now we have
been campaigning on this well before the
pandemic you know we shouldn't be in
this place State education in this in
this country is right on the edge and
it's that way because of the government
and the decisions they've taken the fact
that the Neu and teachers are responding
in this way shouldn't be any surprise to
anyone okay well that's straight at you
then Justine Greening we're coming on
for 13 years of conservative government
tender you were part of that and part of
the that education system that John is
saying has actually been neglected on
your watch well first of all
for me it was a privilege to be
education secretary I absolutely loved
that job it'll be the best role I ever
get to do in my life and I actually very
much enjoyed working with the unions and
I tried to make sure that we had a
constructive relationship and you're
always going to have discussions
disagreements and debates with the Union
but what we tried to genuinely do was to
not stop that from working on a broader
agenda on education where we could agree
and I I genuinely think that someone
like Jillian Keegan is in a similar
place where she really does care about
social Mobility I think the the key now
is for a discussion on pay to take place
you know that needs to be resolved one
way or another but I think there needs
to be a broader discussion around how we
can put in place that long-term plan on
education that can not just help young
people and children catch up post
covered but can close the gaps that open
up in our education system that they
mean we do not have a Britain with a
quality of opportunity I just want to
bring in Jennifer here here on that
before we lose lose track of it the
point that Justine was making you know
very very passionately we're all
passionate about it about the innocent
parties in all this the the students the
young people who are missing out on
crucial years crucial times in their
education absolutely you know I know
people who this year their children are
doing gcses and it's you know the it's
going to be the first postcovid fully
marked they're expecting grades to go
down and now these parents are like oh
no you know what's going to happen
specifically with my my own child's
education then we're aware you know
vulnerable children
send children all those things but also
I think it's it is exactly what
Justine's saying that these strikes and
the inability for everyone to kind of
come together and get something done
will affect these children right now it
will affect their education for years to
come you could say the next decade or so
but also there's a knock-on effect
overall it's going to affect the economy
parents that have to stay home and sort
out everything try to do and try to
teach their children at home we know
women are going to be particularly
affected because they're the ones that
tend to stay home will they get paid
time off to look after their children
during this time there's just it's going
to affect all the things that are really
important for us to focus on right now
just while you're still with us we've
got a question on that thank you very
much indeed for raising it Jennifer a
question asking what impact would pay
Rises have on the UK's economy and of
course there are the strike action
itself has that effect that Jennifer was
describing that so many other Industries
and areas of economic activity have a
knock-on effect because people actually
can't go into work because they've got
to care for their children but in terms
of when they're quite similar problems
for different reasons that that your
Administration the administration your
partner was struggling with is that you
know limited amount of money around you
know the whole of government has to be
looked at here the whole of government
spending what impact would pay Rises for
teachers have on the UK's economy would
it be inflationary would it lead to
higher deficits I think I think if you
talk to economists
um they will say if you're if you're
adding costs into a supply chain and
production then of course pay going up
will feed through I think when it comes
to public sector pay there's far less of
a case to be made that that pay will
directly flow through into inflation I
think there's a genuine question which
is why the pay review is important
around what is the market how are we
going to make make sure there's a
competitive reward structure for
teachers so that we have the level of
teachers that we need and that is just a
question of fact and reality
and of course that's what the payroll
review boards are there to do I think
the challenge that the government's also
got is that as a secretary of state you
write your letter to the pay review
board to say here are the issues that I
can see maybe there's more of a focus on
recruitment maybe there's a focus on
retention sometimes your moral focus is
the government I think has been on new
teachers and making sure that that's a
competitive pay to come in other times
you may be looking further up the scale
and it's about school leadership but the
bottom line is I think the challenge
this year
is that because of the inflation impact
all of that analysis work that was done
in the DFE
at the time that those letters were
being written and then the pay review
board themselves it's kind of been
overtaken by the economics of the
situation so what we now need I think is
for everyone to recognize that we have
actually got a pretty good process for
looking at pay and understanding whether
it works in the market but actually the
economy has just shifted quite
significantly and so the sooner people
can get around the table work out how to
get through this for our children and
young people the better could I ask a
question can I ask you a question so
because some of this is about short-term
economics isn't it the long-term impact
of this the long-term economics is as
Kevin Collins who I know and work with
as well said unless you invest in these
kids the long tail of their under
investment is going to be massive if we
want a winning economy in the future is
there not a place Justine for investing
been talking about you know mass and
getting more into technology and
bringing up that education well I've
never heard a government that doesn't
talk about education
they want to get elected in two years
time and they don't want to have a
massive deficit and tax Rises to go and
go into the election and that's why you
have to have much longer term thinking
from the treasury you know we used to be
in a world where investment in physical
capital and Roads and infrastructure was
how you powered the economy now it's as
much about human capital it's about us
and our people and whether we can you
know have the talent that our our
businesses need I work with lots of
businesses through my social Mobility
work uh they help at the same time as we
Face a cost of living crisis Dermot we
haven't got the skills these companies
needing great careers great jobs so
actually leveling up and powering the
economy and improving productivity go
hand in hand you're not going to fix
that overnight
and so you come back to the teacher
strike and and in the sense how
counterproductive that is to that whole
mission we have as a country on leveling
up and what you'll need to do is not
just look at pay but look at the wider
teaching profession with all that in
mind then what about a couple of extra
billion I don't know how much it would
cost just to say I'm sure that's worth
it isn't it I'm sure those are the
debates that are happening inside
government but it's more than that for
teachers as well it's around the
environment they're working in it's
around continue professional development
it's the career itself and making sure
that it's not just the pay that's
appealing the broader career itself is
something that I know teachers are
hugely passionate about it's a vocation
it's a vocation and that's what you need
to work with in the coming years I think
also we need to pay attention to the
role that schools play over on the
communities you know wrap around care
breakfast clubs all that kind of extra
life affirming well-being
um learning that's not necessarily book
learning but teaching kids how to be
socialized and being a kind of focus for
the community that's going to be in our
next section John Hayes will have an
awful lot to say about that we'll be
coming back to you John very soon but
for the time being thank you very much
indeed Justin greeney for for coming
along to share your your expertise and
your inside knowledge with us it's been
so so valuable uh and you are watching a
Sky News Tonight special program about
the teacher strike coming up next as I
say we're going to be discussing more on
how children are going to be affected by
the strikes and whether they'll affect
exams of course there's summer exams so
important uh more coming up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to the Sky News
tonight question and answer program
about the teacher's strike coming up in
England and Wales or strikes I should
say uh let's bring bring back in our
panel for today's program and then we'll
get to some more of your questions about
the strikes will affect in particular
children we got the founder of the Oasis
Academy's trust Steve chalk also joined
by the editorial director of nat mums
Jennifer house and the NAU member and
head teacher at gospelo Primary School
John Hayes joins us from Hertfordshire
so as I say this section we're going to
concentrate um on the effect on children
but uh to start it off let's just get a
sense of the the scale of it and this
question is just what type of schools
will be affected from Gina and Johnny
well certainly well let's start with
what you know John certainly certainly
your school
yeah most certainly I think it's any
school where any EU members are working
I think all Nu members are covered by
the strike action uh and I believe
anyone who joins the Neu from today will
equally be covered uh so I I think it's
going to be very very widespread uh well
Steve you can talk as as we say you know
with plenty of schools for you to look
after or all your schools presumably
will be affected you all have any new
members yeah all of our schools will be
affected by this that doesn't mean all
of our schools will shut by the way and
I think a really key part of this as I'm
sure John will say there is no any you
my uh worker a staff worker who will be
striking who isn't concerned about the
kids and because these uh days out the
withdrawal of Labor doesn't start until
next month and we've got all the days
there'd be lots just as there has been
in the past lots and lots and lots of
planning you've got to remember that
here I am as the leader of this school's
Network and I'm employee and if you like
it's it's a not it's a charity not just
me employing these people but they're my
friends they're my colleagues yes we
work together is there a danger here of
this because the the any any you have
voted to go on strike but not the NES
uwt or the nht you're gonna have picket
lines you may have you may have some
members your friends and colleagues
Crossing those picket lines but
everybody understands the same thing so
in the past when there's been these
actions the teams that have been
striking have sat down with everybody
else as they will do from tomorrow
morning onwards and their think through
so how do we keep this school open if we
possibly can how do we rearrange the
curriculum bring groups together perhaps
show them films related to uh their
curriculum and their subjects we will
work as hard as we can to keep all of
our schools open and I know the Neu
members will help us do that because of
Jennifer's Point schools are not just
about geography maths history Etc
they're about they're about meal they're
about socialization they're about
emotional support and they're also about
supporting parents hard-working and
underpaid parents in our case so though
they can go out just let me ask John go
back to John come to you in a moment or
two Jennifer I know you've got some
really important points to make but just
John on that in terms of how operational
your school will be you make any
preparations for it or are you as an any
human be yourself you're just going to
close it up close it down entirely
no we'll have to look at the advice that
we get and I've no doubt the leadership
of the Nu will be issuing lots of that
for Neu leader members uh very soon so
that we understand what we're going to
do I think one of the things that we had
to consider that you know many years ago
and the last time we took strike action
was health and safety issues so
dependent on the number of teachers who
are out on strike it may be that it's
just not safe to keep the school open
because you can't necessarily limit the
children who are going to come in
um so we you know you have to make a
decision based on on keeping people safe
keeping children safe
um so there will be a lot of preparation
a lot of discussion and planning between
now and the first of those strike days
but I'm I'm optimistic that maybe the
government will take us seriously now
and get round the table tomorrow
um and start talking so that we don't
have to go on strike that would be the
best outcome for everybody still away to
go okay this question Jennifer you've
touched on it all already and we're all
so concerned about it what will be the
impact on children's education after
covid after months of lockdowns at a
crucial point in their educational
careers exactly there are so many
families that the the children and the
parents feel like they're at breaking
point and that here we go again it's all
suddenly we might be with these strikes
putting basically parents and children
back into lockdown but everybody else is
you know still going to work or whatever
but they're having to really
um you know take on the education not be
able to go into work really trying to
manage it all losing money themselves if
they can't get paid time off to look
after their children
and I think also it was very interesting
we were polling our community today and
that Mom's 25 percent are worried about
the mental health effects of themselves
as parents I think you know there's a is
a whole constellation of issues it's
education it's a mental health of
children because there are a lot of
children still trying to bounce back
um educationally and emotionally you
know learning how to be more socialized
and learning how to be at school and
then you have the parents themselves who
might be struggling whose income might
have taken a hit during covid and now
during the cost of living crisis and now
this is happening as well I think I I
can't really overstate basically uh I
was talking to somebody
um on our staff today she said oh my
kids were jumping for joy and I was just
thinking what am I going to do and
encapsulated and Steve but you know
mentioning you know the long-tailed
effect of covid we've got that you know
what happened just in terms of the the
education you've missed and the mental
health issues you you may have got the
behavioral problems you may have
developed but they're also and we
touched on that with Justine Greening
large numbers of children who've
disappeared from the roles haven't
returned and also
changed and some of their carers
attitude towards schooling that you know
it's a bit optional now going to school
you can always catch up on you know Zoom
or the teachers will send you something
and you'll be fine yeah that I mean that
no doubt it's a factor estimates vary
don't they but at least a hundred
thousand children are missing what we
call persistently absent from school
persistently absent means by the way
absent for more than 10 of the time but
here's the thing we call them school
refusers it's a strange thing because
say your child has a broken leg and they
can't go to school or the flu or covid
we don't say their school refuses we say
they're ill if a child is meant that has
mental health problems or parents have
mental health problems and for some
reason they're locked into a world
postcovid where they just can't face
school we call them school refusers but
actually they are mental health issues
and that's why Kevin Collins advice
Kevin Collins advice about invest in
heavily in the mental health care of
kids and parents was so important and
was ignored and that's why he left
that's why he walked out made by birth
in genevae just another specific
question a quick one for you John Hayes
um will strikes affect exams will
students get more help we're a way off
but um you know certainly everyone's got
those in mind those summer exams coming
up
I'm a primary teacher I don't yet know
that to what extent the strike days will
coincide with the exams and exam
preparation but but I do I think we do
need to put all of this in some kind of
perspective we're talking about
um I think the Neu has said no more than
four days uh of strike action hopefully
it will be fewer than that the the dates
that have been published are many weeks
apart
you know what we need to look at is put
this in perspective 13 years of
underfunding from this government for
State education 13 years that's that's
hundreds of thousands of children who've
been through our schools as they have
gradually lost staff and had fewer and
fewer resources available to support
those children you know the days that
we're talking about for teachers to take
strike action when you put it in that
context is relatively small children
need to be in school on time every day I
my the parents that that I work with
have heard me say that endlessly and I
totally believe it but right now we've
got to look at the danger the damage
that is being done to children in school
now the ones who are in school aren't
getting what they need they the special
needs children are not getting what they
need and we have to stand up and say
enough is enough so a couple of days off
yeah it's not great and it's it's going
to be inconvenient I get that and I'm a
parent my kids are grown up so it won't
affect me in the same way but it would
have done when they were at school age
um I get that that level of
inconvenience but we've got to look at
the bigger picture 13 years of
underfunding and a few days of strike
action I think we need to take take some
perspective exactly there's some very
important perspective there and as you
said earlier it might not even come to
that there's still time for these even
these strikes that are planned to be
averted we're going to take another
break when we come back we'll be
discussing our parents will be affected
by the teachers going on strike more
about that after the break
foreign
I was about five years ago now I'm 23
now I had a really positive experience
um all of my friends and family were
really really supportive
um I have to admit though I often joke
that the hardest thing about being trans
is the admin and and I think there's a
lot of Truth to that it's been one of
the the biggest barriers one of the
biggest hurdles uh for me um I've been
able to update things like my passport
my driving license
Etc to reflect my my name uh and my my
gender and the one thing that I've not
been able to do is update my birth
certificate and and that's because that
requires one of these gender recognition
certificates
um in order to do that that's all the
gender recognition certificate does
actually it allows you to update your
birth certificate and that means that if
you're getting married and you can make
sure that the marriage is being recorded
with you and you're correct gender and
means also that if you pass away and
that you can have dignity in death by
ensuring that the death certificate is
recorded correctly now I've been not
I've not been able to to get that
certificate and because I've been on the
waiting list for the NHS gender identity
clinics for that medical diagnosis uh
for coming up for five years now I've
not had an initial appointment yet I'm
still waiting I don't know when that's
going to be and that means that under
the current process if I wanted to get
that gender recognition certificate to
update my birth certificate I would have
to pay for a private psychiatric
assessment I mean that costs hundreds of
pounds on top of all of the other costs
related to Gathering all of the the you
know other documents that they ask you
to submit to this sort of panel of
so-called experts who will never
actually meet you to determine whether
you're man enough or woman enough to
update your birth certificate and so
that's been a real barrier to me and so
I was really really excited and really
happy that the the the the Bell uh in
Scotland that you know we've been
campaigning on for so so long uh finally
passed back in December to make that
process just a little bit easier I'm in
the man Rashid and I'm Skies north of
England correspondent telling stories
from this culturally Rich region I call
home
welcome back to a Sky News Tonight
program on the teacher strike in England
and Wales and uh we're looking in this
section our final section on the impact
on parents and we went out to hear from
some parents in Bristol what they
thought about it all just when the
strikes were announced and these were
some of their thoughts
to be honest I support where they're
coming from I think they're massively
underpaid I think they do an amazing job
and if they're not paid and then they
end up leaving then we're going to have
less teachers overall it'll probably
take a bit more planning than just
suddenly close because then
um this could obviously need to do
homeschooling look after the kids we've
got work to think about
so I don't know mixed
yeah I think they probably need to be
paid more but
I don't know if strike catches the way
ahead
a couple of thoughts then let's talk to
our panel again you know them all by now
so I want to ask you about that uh
Jennifer from Man's net um you're
polling
scrambling upgrade
um the um the polling you've done there
genuinely supportive of the teachers yes
yes
um our uh our community they know how
hard teachers work they uh they
appreciate the work we do they get loads
of support for all kinds of things for
their children
um you know beyond regular education and
um more than a majority of them support
the teachers but they are also worried
and I think it's really interesting in
this discussion we're having a really
important discussion about the political
realities behind everything
economics but for most parents it's
about the practicalities you know it's a
this word salad of all these different
unions and where they're going to be
striking and what days and the teachers
might be striking at my school but my
school's still open so do do I have to
send my children who will they be taught
by what will they be doing so at night
moms we're focused on that because we're
getting plenty of questions like that I
mean yeah we've had one here about and
it Shades Echoes of the pandemic here
aren't the key workers can't take time
off which is why of course the the
schools stayed open for the children of
key workers during those lockdowns not
this time John I mean do you get that
what you know what's the attitude
amongst your parents many of whom I
suspect are key workers
I think um we we had our own pay
campaign some years ago
um and the parents were incredibly
supportive uh they signed an open letter
which we took to the DFE and handed in
with parents and children so I think uh
at gospel Oak I think parents will
continue to they know what's going on
um we we've you know our our PTA has
been crucial in in keeping us going
through raising money through charity uh
my school represents an incredibly
diverse population we draw from a whole
series of communities in in the the part
of North London uh where I work and many
of those parents have come forward and
said we'd like to we understand what
pressure under we'd like to make some
donations to your school we shouldn't
have to survive on parent charity so I
think I think parents will be very
supportive I understand that it's it's
going to be corruptive for parents but I
think parents also and they perhaps they
don't know the pressures that the
schools are under educating their
children all of the rest of the time you
know we're under resourced we're
understaffed those are the things that
are having the impact on kids learning
um a couple of days of strike action
isn't going to have the same detrimental
effect that 13 years of Tory government
has had on them okay John is looking at
it in the in the round there now another
specific question Steve chalk you've
touched on this a bit earlier in the
hour the question is how will online
classes take place and again back to the
pandemic back to those lockdowns some
pretty efficient and effective systems
put into place during the course of
those months and years so what about uh
in the Oasis academies what are you
going to do well first of all as as
we've all said a school going home
sending the whole school home is the
last resort in all of this and we work
in all sorts of ways because of the rest
of the care that school needs to bring
but yeah no during the first lockdown we
sat down as Oasis and we we were used to
a situation where some kids have the
privilege of having their own bedroom
and a good internet connection and it's
quiet and it's etc etc and they were
they could do their lesson online and
parents who also were helping them if
they got exactly yeah all of that and
other kids they're in a flat there's
three kids it's squashed they they're
trying to do the same lesson on a crack
screen of an old mobile phone so what we
did and and we don't have any more money
than any other schools we just looked at
ways of investing we went to
um Apple I should say and we bought we
got 32 000 kids in our schools other
technology companies are available yeah
I know yeah but we bought I know yeah we
bought 35
000 iPads
and they said it was the biggest order
ever that put together but you see what
we wanted to ensure was that every child
could learn on the same device so our
lessons were put together for those
devices how did you afford that they
they well we we just invested the money
that we would be spending over the next
three years we brought it forward so it
didn't cost us it cost us more but the
iPad has also created a great connection
with the family so they can ask us
questions Etc so what we can smooth out
those digital qualities yeah all of that
so what we can't that has been fantastic
what we can say we still don't want to
go to remote learning but what we can
say is if that happens our families know
how to use those front I'm sorry we're
out of time it's just been absolutely
fascinating Steve chalk thank you very
much indeed Jennifer how's very good to
see you and John Hayes from gospel Oak
School they're very good to see you
thank you very much indeed for your
expertise uh you've been watching a Sky
News Tonight special question and answer
session about about the teachers strike
coming up at eight o'clock we'll be
discussing that industrial action in
Greater detail
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]